that's in today's tutorial we'll see how
to build the gas DX game using only HTML
CSS and jQuery mr shed and before we
begin the tutorial let's see a demo and
the final version of the game so this is
the game we have some eggs falling down
and we have a basket and that moves with
the mouse okay we'll have to cast X to
update the score and we'll have 20 lives
then each egg falls we will lose one
life and the speed of the eggs will
increase after a certain interval so
that's it
it's this really simple game so let's
see what we have here we have a
container this one and we have a place
to see the score life and help a help
text and we have three hands one branch
3x a basket and a floor and of course
the reset button ok now let's see the
files that we are going to work with we
have an index dot HTML file style dot
CSS script DOJ's file a function DOJ's
file and a variable dot JS file I have
already done the index dot HTML and this
childhood CSS file so that I won't be
redoing it but I'll explain it okay
let's see what would we have in the
index.html file but before that let's go
and open this
in the browser
okay let's close the other one okay we
have a very basic HTML template with a
head and a body in the head there is a
title and a link to this childhood CSS
file and in the body we have a container
and inside the container we have so many
dips the first one is the score help div
which consists of the score and the life
and we have the branch div and we have
three divs with the same class hen and
different IDs hen 1 n 2 and n 3 and then
we have three other divs with the same
class egg these are for the eggs when
but with different IDs egg 1 egg 2 and X
3 we also have we also have a data
attribute here the doubles I 1 2 & 3
I'll explain this later okay and we have
three similar divs with the same class
bullseye and with different IDs will say
1 2 & 3
okay next we have the basket div inside
that we are showing the score and then
we have the floor and the reset button
and before ending the body we have
included jQuery door/window J's and the
collision detection door JS file I think
you know you all know about jQuery we
are using jQuery scripting to script the
game and the collision detection is it's
a simple function that returns when
passed to diffs it will detect whether
the divs have collided or not that's
very simple okay
okay our scripting will be in script
O'Jays function DOJ's and the variable
DOJ's file as as you can see I have
already declared all the variables that
are required for the game I'll explain
it later after I explain CSS now let's
go to CSS let's see what we have here
the HTML and body nothing like just
width height margin and font family and
for the container that this red bordered
div the container has height with a
margin left to to make it at the center
of the div a margin left of 5% and
position is relative and border overflow
and background color simple CSS and next
we have the score help div which has a
text-align:center phone sales and
background color then we have the branch
we whose position is absolute which has
a height of 2 percent and width
background and top then we have the
comment class hand for all those hands
its position is also absolute and height
width top and a background image we are
using a background image for the hand
all those three hands and background
size is covered and wagon repeat as
no-repeat to position it correctly and
the middle index of 102 style each of
them to position each of them at three
different places like this one here
another one here and the third one here
for that we have hen one left as 20% and
to 40% and three and 60% and we have the
common class egg it's like the hen
position:absolute top and the background
color ball ready a sense that said let's
your HTML there's no you know images for
that and to style it separately egg one
is positioned left calculate 20% 20% is
the left of the hen okay so now the left
of the egg is at the left of the hen but
what we want is to position the egg the
exposition the extender position should
be at the center of the hand so the
calculation would be like 20% + 8 % / -
this 8% is the width of the hen and -
this is the width of the egg so that its
position center will be at the center of
the hem likewise egg - with 40% and x3
with 60% calculation now we have the
bullseye which display will be none this
is the common class of those three
bull's-eyes and this bottom height with
background we are using an image here
okay and background size back on Colin
and z-index 11 and now to style it
separately to position it left is almost
the same as X 20 40 and 60 next we have
the floor which is this one
it's [ __ ] is absolute height with
background-color bottom and Z Linux
nothing much and then we have the basket
which height width position bottom and
the background we are using any PNG file
here of a basket okay and the bagger
repeating background size
text-align:center and Z index now the
score one which is the school that is
displayed inside the basket it's a
position color phone size top and left
that's it you can play with this if you
want you know next we have at last we
have the reset button whose boarder
position height width background color
and everything else and the distal
button is hidden when the game starts so
it's display is set to none okay so
that's all about the CSS and HTML let's
see it here we can see it here yes
everything is looking fine
like I said before the variable DOJ's
file
I have already declared some variables
to use in our script this are just maybe
it was this basket I have selected the
basket object container container object
hen the common class hen X comma class
egg egg 1 2 & 3 Rhys Todd scores fans
call one lifespan floor basket height
container height egg height X initial
position before the game starts that
will be the pass in the vector CSS top
ok score live speed max speed counter
score updated things like that and the
basket talked it we don't have the
basket stop CSS stops so we calculate it
by using container hide - basket head
you know that gives baskets top
container height - baskets height that
will give the basket stop okay sorry
okay using the life variable we are
setting the lifespans text as life which
is 0 or sorry it's 5 set of five already
okay now before we do anything let's go
and include the script Doge's the
variables DOJ's file here variables door
chase okay fine
let's see the life gets updated yes life
is getting updated
so let's start the scripting before that
lets include script or J's also scrim
projects is included so everything we
are going to write will be in st. the
document already function so the older
function
that's the game will be our function
this will be executed repeatedly that's
how the animation works so in order to
do that we'll have to use a JavaScript
default method called the
requestanimationframe
and inside that will pass the function
which here is d game now we don't have
anything in here just console.log one
two three in order to execute this
repeatedly we'll have to call this
inside the function again so let's see
whether it's working or not console yes
one two three is getting printing
repeatedly so let's go there and emotive
this one main thing the
requestanimationframe it returns an ID
which can be used later to stop the
animation let's assign it to a variable
called animal you know we'll have to
update it here also okay I'll show you
the use of console animation frame the
cancel admission frame if we pass the
anime ID there first let's commend this
and see open the console and see how
many times it gets executed
with Chris animation frame of the game
the game sorry if you don't have the
console dot log here can solve dot log
one two three okay it's getting executed
like repeatedly so if we uncomment this
canceled an omission of any my and him
ID it gets executed once and then it
stops when the code read this code it
will stop the execution of the this
animation the game so let's read that
see first we want to move the egg first
let's concentrate on egg one instead of
doing everything so how are we going to
move the egg down this is the egg one
now its top is 18% so it doesn't matter
whether it's in percentage or pixels if
we increase the top see all the eggs
coming down so that's how we bring the
eggs down so let's write that first
let's make the function egg down of
first let we have already selected egg
one in the variable store J's here so
first let's play with egg one egg down
let's go and define this function in the
functions to J's fire function egg down
this changes variable to egg
so in order to increase the top of the
egg we'll have to we'll have to get the
current oh so like egg current positions
available is pass in dove we'll have to
use passing because otherwise the xes
stops px will come with each C egg dot
CSS top that's the X current position so
here using egg dot CSS dope we are
getting the X CSS top now we'll have to
set the xes top so egg dot CSS top is
egg current position plus say two pixels
let's see what happens nothing is
happening
it's good oh I think I forgot to include
the function to J's file in the script
yes that's true
functions churches functions to test
okay
egg one is coming down and it's going
out of the container and that's not what
we want before setting the egg to its
initial pose and let's move the basket
how are you going to do that we let's
before everything dough command dot on
Mouse sorry Mouse move function and
let's get event there
basket have selected already dot CSS
left ye dot page X so whenever the mouse
moves this will set the basket CSS left
as the Mouse's exposition let's see
whether it works or not
yes it's working perfectly so that's
working now we'll have to bring the eggs
to its initial position when it hits the
floor let's do that first
okay let's do it over here if Czech egg
hits floor of we check sake one let's
write this function first define this
function over here function egg is the
floor how are we going to do that we
have the egg and we have the floor and
we have the collision detection function
so it's really easy if collision of egg
that we have passed and the floor that
we have selected in the variable G s
return true else return false that's how
we'll check whether the egg hits the
floor or not script or J's file if check
against the floor if it's true let's set
the x position to its initial position
that that was somewhere like behind the
hen and we have the X initial position
here it's already declared so let's
write a function set egg to initial
position
and we check the egg 1 Kim let's define
this function function DoDEA's function
set back to initial position changes to
egg 1 egg 1 2 egg
so how we're going to do that say that
we did here egg dot CSS stop let's copy
this base here instead of a current
position say egg initial position okay
this will set the egg that's egg CSS top
two it takes initial position let's see
whether it works or not
egg is going to hit the floor yes the
loop continues now there's one more
thing remaining with the floor and egg
when egg hits the floor we'll have to
show the bullseye let's see how we can
do that see he this is the place we are
checking whether the egg hits the floor
or not so let's do it here if collision
of a comma floor say bullseye show
bull's eye of what egg this egg that
would be egg one that sparks from the
script OJ's file let's define this
function so we'll say
so now we'll have to identify which bull
side to show so we know what to do that
that's why I told you at the beginning
of the game I will explain about this
data attribute you know when this object
is passed
when egg one is pass it will have access
to this data attribute and this is a to
one so that it will be easy for us to
understand which will side to show see
it here in action say bullseye num okay
is AG dot attribute the double say that
uh bullseye if if one hits the floor now
the eggs that would will be one if it's
- its - and if it's free it's free okay
we have the bullseye num here now let's
show the bullseye hash bullseye
Plus bullseye now
don't show so this will show if it's egg
1 this will show bull Sonam will return
one and this hash bullseye + bulls annum
will get select the object will say 1
with ID bullseye 1 and it will show it
let's see take is coming down it's going
to hit the floor
nothing's happening
let's see show bullseye of egg egg
thought attr bullseye okay
okay it's dateable sigh the attributes
name is their double sigh okay that's
why it's not working I guess
see if it is coming down it's a floor
yeah bull's-eyes on now we want the both
side to disappear so if we hide the
busie here itself say hide
we won't be able to see it because
immediately after it is shown it will be
hidden so let's do something else
let's call hide bull's-eye function from
here and pass the bullseye numb
yeah okay
and that's hide bullseye function and
it's possible seinem paste this here
bullseye bullseye nom dot hide no not
like that
let's put this in a set timeout function
so that it will execute after some time
say 800 millisecond
let's see what weather is working or not
it's the floor so the Volt's ha yeah but
sighs gone now the second time which I
came and it's gone yeah that's what we
want
now next thing we want to check and
return the position of the know before
that let's reduce the score when the
reduced life when the egg hits the floor
let's do that first
yeah so this one where if egg is a flow
show bullseye and decrement life okay
function decrement life we already have
the life variable set so life - - lets
show in the life span life and this one
more thing that's the life this Dell no
life is only yeah life span detects life
see that here we have the life
yeah it's decrementing that's done now
okay now let's write the code for
catching dick which means egg hits the
basket so in script OJ's so if a chick
egg hits the floor and okay let's write
it here poor ol Czech egg heads basket
of egg one yeah yeah in both these
situations we'll have to set the egg to
initial position okay so check it gets a
basket function check egg hits the
basket
so now to do that check whether if
collision of egg coma basket we can
return true else return false
this here's the basket it's going to the
its initial position let's update the
score also when it hits a basket yes
potential update score sorry the
function
function update score which will update
the score we already have the score
let's write and it's updating the score
spanned the text score then there's one
more place inside the basket that's I
think it's cool one yeah it's called one
dot text all these variables are inside
the video so J's file ok score yeah
let's see when it hits the basket with
the score gets updated or not see the
score is changing okay no that's done
but we have a problem here this is a
successful catch but there's one more
successful kids if the egg hits the side
of the basket also the scoring freezes
that's not what we want right so we'll
have to add one more condition during
the egg hitting the basket the collision
of egg and the basket we'll have to
check one more condition that is the egg
stop is still less than the basket stop
so that we can see that egg is still
just above the basket it's already
collided but X top is still above the
basket so let's add that condition over
here okay all these will come inside
that if we don't have the X table
underscore top top is passing dove egg
dot CSS top yes
see and I think hope you already have
the basket stop here yeah but contain
hide - basket ideas that's Eric so if
egg top is less than basket top
when the egg collides with the basket
make sure the X stop is still less than
basket shop because when Dex
top is greater than basket which means
it already this situation like the egg I
had already passed the basket okay we
don't want that so that's why we are
checking X drop is still less than the
basket top when the collision happens
then our bread score and return true
just check that okay that's not updating
this core okay no if we do this yes
that's updating the score and that sir
that's a catch yes
okay now let's I think everything is
done for catching the egg I bet in the
score if the egg hits the floor showing
bullseye and what are you decrementing
the life but the here is a problem it's
getting like it's decrementing more to
not stop that let's go to the script oh
jeez this is getting called everytime so
we don't want that to happen so well if
life is greater than zero then do this
else see else that says a new stop the
game and let's pass the any mighty or
we'll get that anybody there
see stop the game good to function DOJ's
function stop the game you all know that
cancel mission frame is the thing that
we are any my D to C with the 5 so 4 3 2
will have to wait 2 & 1
if it hits zero yeah the game stopped so
that's what we want now let's do the
same for all the X but before that let's
write a small condition here see if this
condition then sex attacked initial
position and let's write an else
condition here else egg down it's just
the simple right
if it's the floor or or egg it's a
basket and septic to initial position
that time we don't want egg to come down
this is JavaScript so it won't wait for
the if this else is not there it won't
wait for the this execution to happen
and it will process this so the egg will
come down even if it's the floor or the
basket we don't want that if it's a
floor and or the egg is a basket we will
have to set the ektu its initial
position or else we'll have to make the
eggs come down that's it now
let's do copy-paste this for all those X
the X 2 and X 3 CX to copy paste paste
and paste and this will be act 3 copy
paste paste and paste yes
actually here I'm not using it
completely using the visual studio cords
or features here
that's when pasting copying and pasting
every time I see all the eggs are coming
down
yes it's the floor game got over we
still go 1-1 but it's fine it's okay we
can write a conditioner when the score
is getting updated if it's not less than
zero updated okay now let's see whether
the score works or not if I cast the egg
yeah it's working fine yeah three four
and five
yeah so that's one more thing to do
because now the eggs are falling is slow
you know throughout the game the same
speed okay let's sing that we have the
egg down function in here we are using a
static variable Beck and in d'azur - we
don't want that we can choose the speed
over here script or Jace no variable
O'Jays we have already declared this the
change is to speed and let's sing the
speed when some condition is satisfied
let's say when the score is a multiple
of ten like ten if it's ten will
increase the speed by one and if it's 20
you willing to speed with one and like
that the speed increases so where are we
increasing the speed score it's here
yeah after increasing if the check
whether if score percent ten is zero
then speed
plus plus so I know to test this let's
change this to two one and get that hick
to see the speed increase for ya
increase seven in Greece yeah that's the
only given life five okay so this st. is
210 so that in Greece and one important
thing there should be a maximum speed
otherwise we won't be able to we won't
be able to see whether the egg is Craig
has collided with the floor or basket
okay so let's do that and and score is
less than or equals max code max no no
it's not cold it's beep speed is less
than max speed so there's a maximum
speed for the X if it's more than that
we won't be able to this is just D van
collision so if it moves with more speed
the function will not be able to check
in that moment whether it has collided
or not okay that's issue here we so
we're dynamically changing the speed V
we can do you're updating the score
we're determining the life everything
now let's when the game is over let's
show the reset button it's easy
restart dot
slide on this given animation slide down
okay the next fall okay it came down but
nothing happens when we click that let's
restart don't click function this reload
location
okay yes yep yeah research is working
fine so that's it
isn't that simple that's what I said
it's very simple you can play with that
you can play with the life you can
increase the life you can change the way
the score is our life is reduced or the
score is increased and the speed is
increased so feel free to play with that
I'll update the code and github and
provide the description provide the link
in the description so if you like this
game and if you write like my tutorials
please feel free to like the video share
the video and subscribe to my channel so
until next time bye